-Welcome back to the show,
everybody.
It is fall.
The weather's
getting a little chilly.
It's time to break out
the hats and gloves.
And with that in mind,
it's time to play the game
that's sweeping the nation.
It's time for
"Dance Your Hat and Gloves Off."
-♪ "Dance Your Hat
and Gloves Off ♪
♪ Come on and dance 'em off ♪
-Welcome to
"Dance Your Hat and Gloves Off."
Release the mirror ball!
There you go. This...
[ Laughter ]
This is the game where we put
hats and gloves on people
and make them dance
until they fall off.
Now let's meet our contestants.
Come on over, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Looking good.
Looking good
in the neighborhood.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-Spencer Jones
from Tyler, Texas.
-Hey! Tyler, Texas.
Spencer,
thank you for being here.
What's your name?
Where are you from?
-Nadiah Malik.
Freehold, new Jersey.
-Oh, yeah!
-Whoo!
-Guest number three.
-Davis Roper.
Raleigh, North Carolina.
-Oh, wow! Davis, Raleigh.
Now, are you guys
ready to do this?
-We're ready.
-Here you go.
Here's how the game works.
One at a time, you'll take
your place on the dance floor.
Don't be worried about that
mirrorball. It will not fall.
It hasn't yet. It hasn't yet.
But when I say "dance,"
you're going to have 15 seconds
to fling your hat
and gloves off.
Scoring is simple -- 1 point
for each glove you get off,
2 points for the hat.
Whoever gets the most points
wins the grand prize.
And, oh, what a prize it is.
Higgins?
-Well, Jimmy, tonight's winner
will be taking home
a treasure map
that shows the precise
location of three $100 bills
that are vacuum-sealed
and floating in the middle
of the Atlantic Ocean.
Jimmy?
-Yeah!
-Thank you. Higgins.
Thank you, Higgins.
What would you do
with that $300, Higgins?
-Wow. Thanks for asking.
You know, my son's been needing
a little money --
needs some dental work done.
And I was hoping to take
that $300 and --
-A couple of things
before we start.
At no time can you touch
the hat or gloves,
nor can anything touch them.
Basically, you just have to whip
your arms and head around
as crazy as you can
until everything falls off.
In the event of a tie,
our audience will decide
the winner
based on your dancing skills.
So bring it.
You ready for this?
-We're ready.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, buddy,
you are up first.
Audience, let's cheer him on.
You can hit the dance star
right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Alright. Ready...
set...dance!
Yeah. That's it. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah! Come on! Go!
Come on!
Unh! Unh! Unh! Unh!
Come on! Yeah! Unh! Go!
Come on! Yeah! Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
That's it.
Oh, nice try. Nice job.
It's harder than it looks.
It's much easier at home, when
you're playing the home game.
-That's true.
-Yeah. But that was fantastic.
Can we see what you did
in slow motion
so you can see, as well?
That's what you basically did.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, fanta--
[ Laughs ]
That's fantastic.
Is that how you dance
at weddings, as well?
-I do.
-Yeah, that's right. Well done.
Higgins, how many points?
Ooh! Alright. There you go.
That's right.
Hey, if everyone gets zero,
you still get a good chance.
That was a good style.
Contestant number two,
you are up,
so why don't you hit
the dance spot
whenever you're ready to go.
Audience, cheer her on, please.
Ready...
set...dance!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, yeah! Oh, yeah!
That's 2 points! Yes!
Go, go! Hey, go!
Oh!
[ Dinging ]
That's fantastic! Unbelievable!
Unbelievable! Wow!
That is fant--
Come on over here.
That is definitely
unbelievable moves.
You are in the lead.
Can we see that
in slow motion, please?
Look at this.
Hat came right off.
And then --
Yeah, and then -- What?
You felt it right there.
One, two, three,
bam, right there!
Fantastic job.
Higgins, how many points?
Ooh, ooh, wow.
Oh, there you go!
It's a perfect score.
Perfect score.
But you know what that means.
We're down to our
last contestant here.
Now, you got to show up.
-A lot of pressure.
-Yeah, over in
Raleigh, North Carolina,
do they do some wild dancing?
-You know it.
Better than anywhere else.
-Now, you're happy with
your glasses remaining on?
-We'll find out.
[ Laughter ]
-I like this. I like this.
I kind of want to see them
fly off a little bit, yeah.
-Me too, me too.
-That 300 bucks, if you find it
in the Atlantic Ocean,
could pay for new frames.
-Worth it, worth it.
-Yeah, it is so worth it.
Alright, why don't you
go over here,
and whenever you're ready --
I'll move these out of
the way here so you don't...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to make sure
you're in the clear.
You're okay? You're ready to go?
-I'm ready. I'm ready.
-Okay, audience,
put your hands together.
Ready, set...dance!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Whoa, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Yes!
[ Dinging ]
That -- Wow!
That was fantastic!
Oh, my gosh!
That's never happened
in the history of
"Dance Your Hat and --"
You feel like...
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I know, I know.
Don't even tell me.
Let's see what you did
in slow motion.
Look at this.
Yeah. One, two.
Get that other one off.
You're focused.
Yes! You felt the headbang,
and the glasses stayed on.
Then now look at this. Yes!
Yes! That was like...
That was well done.
Higgins, how many points
did he get there?
That's it right there -- 4.
That's not bad.
But that means our audience
has to decide the winner.
Yeah.
You can have a seat,
if you'd like.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Yeah. No. No, please.
Is it contestant number two?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or is it contestant
number three?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-Contestant number
three is the winner!
Congratulations!
Here is your treasure map
for $300 hidden
in the Atlantic Ocean.
This has been
"Dance Your Hat and Gloves Off."
Thank you for playing,
and thanks to you,
all you boys and girls and
friends and fans in TV land.
From the jocks and rockers
to the bobbysoxers
to the TikTok kids
with all the rizz,
just dig that scene,
if you know what I mean,
and you just might be
on the dancing queen.
So tell your friends
to catch all the action.
I'm on the next season
of "Naked Attraction."
[ Laughter ]
I got a real small part,
if you catch my drift.
It's...
[ Cymbal crash ]
So, so many. It's like an innie.
I guess you could say
I'm a bit of a hunk,
but you need a microscope
to see my junk.
So don't be a meanie,
if you best believe me,
it's a little weeny,
little peeny
that I got in my jeanies.
Just sit right back
and go wick your whack
and don't touch that dial,
'cause we'll be right back
with Uma Thurman, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪